one year ago I came to Davos and told
you that our house is on fire I said I
wanted you to panic I've been warned
that telling people to panic about the
climate crisis is a very dangerous thing
to do but don't worry it's fine
trust me I've done this before and I can
assure you it doesn't lead to anything
and and for the record we're we're
children tell you to panic we're not
telling you to go on like before we're
not telling you to rely on technologies
that don't even exist today at scale and
that science says perhaps never will we
are not telling you to keep talking
about reaching Net Zero emissions or
carbon neutrality by cheating and
fiddling around with numbers we're not
telling you to offset your emissions by
just paying someone else to plant trees
in places like Africa while at the same
time forests like the Amazon are being
slaughtered at an infinitely higher rate
planting trees is good of course but
it's nowhere near enough of what is
needed and it cannot replace real
mitigation and rewilding nature and
let's be clear we don't need a
low-carbon economy we don't need to
lower emissions our emissions have to
stop if we are to have a chance to stay
below the 1.5 degree target and until we
have the technologies that at scale can
put our emissions to - that we must
forget about Net Zero we need real zero
because distant net zero emission
targets will mean
absolutely nothing if we just continue
to ignore the carbon dioxide budgets
that applies for today not distant
future dates if high emissions continue
like now even for a few years that
remaining budgets will soon be
completely used up the fact that the USA
is leaving the Paris Accord seem to
outrage and worry everyone and it should
but the fact that we are all about to
fail the commitments you signed up for
in the Paris agreement doesn't seem to
bother the people in power even the
least any plan or policy of yours that
doesn't include radical emission cuts at
the source
starting today is completely
insufficient for meeting the 1.5 or well
below 2 degree commitments of the Paris
agreements and again this is not about
right or left
we couldn't care less about your party
politics from sustainability perspective
the right the left as well as the center
have all failed no political ideology or
economic structure has been able to
tackle the climate and environmental
emergency and create a cohesive and
sustainable world because of that world
in case you haven't noticed is currently
on fire you say children shouldn't worry
you say just leave this to us we will
fix this we promise we won't let you
down don't be so pessimistic and then
nothing silence or something worse than
silence empty words and promises which
give the impression
that sufficient action is being taken
all the solutions are obviously not
available within today's societies
nor do we have the time to wait for new
technological solutions to become
available to start drastically reducing
our emissions so of course the
transition isn't going to be easy it
will be hard and unless we start facing
this now together with all cards on the
table we won't be able to solve this in
time in the days running up to the 50th
anniversary of the World Economic Forum
I joined a group of climate activists
demanding that you the world's most
powerful and influential business and
political leaders begin to take the
action needed we demand at this year's
World Economic Forum participants from
all companies banks institutions and
governments immediately holds all
investments in fossil fuel exploration
and extraction immediately and all
fossil fuel subsidies and immediately
and completely divest from fossil fuels
we don't want these things done by 2050
2030 or even 20 21 we want this done now
it may seem like we are asking for a lot
and you will of course say that we are
naive but this is just the very minimum
amount of effort that is needed to start
the rapid sustainable transition so
either you do this we are gonna have to
explain to your children why you are
giving up on the 1.5 degree target
giving up without even trying well I'm
here to tell you that's unlike you my
generation will not give up without a
fight the facts are clear but they are
still too
comfortable for you to address you just
leave it because you think it's too
depressing and people will give up but
people will not give up you are the ones
who are giving up last week I met with
Polish coal miners who lost their jobs
because their mine was closed and even
they had not given up on the contrary
they seemed to understand the fact that
we need to change more than you do I
wonder what will you tell your children
was the reason to fail and leave them
facing a climate chaos that you
knowingly brought upon them that it
seemed so bad for the economy that we
decided to resign the idea of securing
future living conditions without even
trying our house is still on fire your
inaction is fueling the flames by the
hour and we are telling you to act as if
you loved your children above all else
thank you
[Applause]